one of the best places to engage in
political discussions with other viewers
and listeners of the David Pakman show
is the david pakman show subreddit i am
a regular on the subreddit i am in there
all the time mixing it up with people so
is producer pat you can find it at david
pakman.com slash read it that's re d di
t a couple of interesting posts i want
to talk about there was an inquiry about
whether it would be difficult for me to
transition over to twitch twitch a live
streaming platform that is huge twitch
TV mostly or at least significantly for
video game streaming which i don't
really play but i have been thinking
about what to do on twitch and i
actually have made an account and i am
going to do a premier stream on twitch
sometime soon i don't exactly know what
to do i had the idea of since the only
thing close to a game that I play is
chess I could livestream some chess
playing play against members of the
audience if they want take questions and
just sort of hang out now someone
reached out and said you know you didn't
really build an audience playing chess
you built an audience talking about
politics so that might be a mistake to
do on Twitch so I don't know exactly
what I would do on twitch twitch has
this requirement if you want to monetize
your content that the content has to be
unique to twitch or at least initially
only on twitch you can later upload it
to youtube if you want but it has to
first be on twitch if you want to
monetize it
so just uploading our YouTube content to
twitch is not I don't even know if it's
possible but it's not something that we
should be doing same thing with
simultaneously streaming to twitch in
YouTube so I'm open to ideas let me know
what you think would be interesting for
me to do on Twitch I'm on Twitch I
believe it's just David Pakman and you
can follow me there in advance of this
extraordinarily compelling premiere that
has yet as of yet not been scheduled but
more importantly let me know what I
could be doing on Twitch that would be
different than what we're doing on our
other platforms interesting and maybe
start to generate an audience there also
from the david pakman show subreddit
white house social media summit to snub
tech giants
most conservative personalities yeah I
was talking to Tim pool yesterday who I
know that despite our political
disagreements it may come as a shock
that we actually are in touch privately
but we've always actually had a good
relationship regardless of our political
disagreements I was talking to him Tim
Poole is invited and it's basically all
right wingers and I said to him Tim it
would be really amazing if you were able
to get on video telling Trump there
really should be some left wingers here
because they're actually also being
affected by all of the issues that we're
talking about and I told him extra
points if he mentions my name to Trump I
don't actually think that he's going to
do it maybe by the time you watch this
clip we will know whether anything like
that happened but yeah I mean that the
the selection of people that were
invited including some I think there was
one person invited to this summit who
has 3,000 followers on Twitter if I
recall correctly if I'm wrong I
apologize but I believe that that's what
I saw and like Google and Facebook
weren't even invited and obviously no
progressive was invited who has an
independent online platform so I don't
know whether any big problems are going
to be solved at this tech summit but I
do look forward to seeing video of it
which may be available by the time you
listen to me talk about this join the
subreddit more than 11,000 of our
viewers and listeners now on the
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT the reddit is not a throwaway
okay the reddit regularly contributes
content to the show I'm personally on
the subreddit I am paying attention to
what's going on there so please please
participate